dozens of cities are putting the final
touches on bits this morning to become
the second headquarters of Amazon the
online giant announced last month its
new location could involve a five
billion dollar capital investment and
50,000 jobs
Amazon wants a diverse city with a large
talent pool mass transit and a high
quality of life but some say that the
company is creating an unfair bidding
war for tax breaks
Tony Tecopa looks at which cities have
the best shot at winning the company's
attention Tony good morning good morning
Amazon has narrowed its search to cities
in North America with an International
Airport and at least a million people
overall beyond that any city has a shot
Boston for example top tier universities
Austin with its high quality of life a
place like New York with a large and
diverse workforce all these cities and
more have until Thursday to get Amazon's
attention and some of their leaders have
been using social media to do it how do
I get Amazon to take notice of Kansas
City Kansas City Mayor Sly James
answered his own challenge by slipping
Kansas City factoids the average home
price is just a hundred and twenty-two
thousand dollars into reviews of a
thousand Amazon products at $14.99 these
wind chimes are music to my ears
Frisco Texas mayor Jeff Chaney got some
help from Dallas Cowboys owner Jerry
Jones we've got it if the flue frisco
flue and really anything goes when vying
for the attention of the world's largest
online retailer which is why Tucson sent
a 21-foot cactus Birmingham planted
these boxes around town so Alexa and
several cities got help from Amazon's
personal assistant Alexa where is the
most interesting company in the world
and ok obviously Washington DC more than
30 cities are expected to submit
proposals Dallas Atlanta and DC checked
most of Amazon's boxes so we asked our
colleagues in those cities why they
stand out everything is bigger in Texas
except for the taxes in Texas there is
no state income or estate tax here in
Dallas Amazon hope will say it's easy to
do business and the cost of living is
the nation's capital has a lot to offer
and Amazon founder Jeff Bezos certainly
has an interest in DC he owns the
Washington Post and he reportedly just
dropped 23 million dollars on this
historic home it's said to be the
largest in Washington
Atlanta also has big starting with the
world's busiest airport and Amazon has a
lot of cargo to ship Georgia Tech would
offer IT support and this city was built
for business recently both Mercedes Benz
and Porsche relocated their North
American headquarters to Atlanta still
some cities aren't getting involved
citing Amazon's emphasis on subsidies
and incentives in a Wall Street Journal
op-ed San Jose Mayor Sam Lew Cardo
called that a bad deal for city
taxpayers San Antonio mayor Ron Berg
added blindly giving away the farm isn't
our style
I think Amazon's gonna come out ahead
it's not really clear if the cities will
Amy Lou's studies urban economics at the
Brookings Institution she warns that
Amazon second city could suffer some of
the same issues and now plaguing its
first Seattle there are real trade-offs
in being the winner Seattle now
experiences high inequality not enough
affordable housing to house workers
Denver Mayor Michael Hancock admits that
growth can have its downsides and is
there a way that you can guarantee that
if Amazon comes here the average rents
not gonna go up no way to guarantee it
there are people out there who don't
necessarily want 50,000 new residents
and a whole lot of traffic on the roads
yeah you know listen we are growing city
and we are charged with managing that
growth mayor Hancock is confident in his
city's charms touting 300 days of
sunshine a year and the Rocky Mountains
it's one of the safest top ten cities in
the country so it's it's it's a
relatively safe fun active lifestyle but
no city is perfect I was the Wi-Fi and
no country is perfect either a reminder
that Amazon second headquarters might
not land in the United States at all
some Canadian cities including Ottawa
and Toronto
are also submitting bids and Canada's
immigration policies could help with
international talent Amazon is expected
to make its decision sometime next year
well it's got to be in the United States
maybe not maybe Detroit we were talking
about it yeah Detroit has a bid that
will involve Windsor City just over the
river there in Canada yeah I'm her twin
city sort of deal well Detroit Lee is in
the running I think that would be great
good happen Buffalo Detroit thank you
Tony thank you Tony